my guests tonight are the storage and
creators of the Emmy award-winning HBO
series Game of Thrones please welcome
executive producers DB Weiss David
Benioff from the cast
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's all the time we have thank
you so much
you know I there's one mistake I made
last year I am NOT going to make it
again last year Liam I ran out of time
before I got to ask you a question it
bothered me very much so I'm going to
start with you this year okay how about
that how do you feel about that yeah
good move dude yeah yeah I got a black I
got a blunt machete bite stage we're
gonna lose a limb if you glowering at me
for God's sake all right I gotta ask you
Liam you have lasted five seasons what
is the secret to not getting killed on
Game of Thrones
all right let me tell you those two boys
they on the end there I've got a sick
sense of humor yeah they're like the air
you can compare them to the air the
heads of the five families in New York
right like you get a phone call to go to
dinner right you don't come back to that
dinner so the trick is don't make good
contact don't pick up the phone don't
pick up the phone don't make eye contact
don't talk to them very very wise how
would you like to see Davos go when he
goes how would you like to see him go
well I've made a couple of suggestions I
think he should go to Dorne
he should drink some some vintage
Dornish wine in the company of a couple
of hookers in an Eightball
I'm not sure what an Eightball is but
that